weiß afghanistan und die frauen rechts
situation in afghanistan
die mich bewegt die mich umtreibt mit
der ich gegenwärtig in den letzten zwei
wochen 24 7 beschäftigt bin weil meine
these ist die bundesregierung hat die
frauen afghanistans im stich gelassen
und es basiert auf aus meiner sicht
darauf dass vor über 20 jahren als die
bundeswehr truppen nach afghanistan
gegangen sind der grund zumindest für
die deutschen bundeswehrsoldaten und
unserer politik war dass wir für die
frauen uns einsetzen müssen dass wir uns
für die partizipation von bildung
einsetzen müssen und im gegensatz zu den
amerikanern die ganz offen gesagt haben
dass es darum geht die al kaida zu
bekämpfen war das der erste grund für
deutsche bundeswehrsoldaten und dass wir
gegenwärtig ausgerechnet diese frauen
meine kolleginnen tv-journalistin
richterin anwältin gerade ausgeliefert
haben der taliban die jetzt eingekesselt
sind die sich mit hilferufen an uns
wenden wir haben den
menschenrechtsorganisationen und wir
kriegen alle zehn minuten kriegen die
hilferufe und e-mails von ich will's
personalisieren von frauen die
richterinnen waren und die taliban
kämpfer ins gefängnis gebracht haben und
diese taliban kämpfer sind ja
freigelassen worden das heißt die
fürchten um leib und leben und es
betrifft nicht nur die frauen sondern
ist betrifft auch beispielsweise schwule
männer also mehr zum beispiel heute
jemand geschrieben der 20 ist der
tätowiert ist und der angst hat dass in
die gliedmaßen abgehackt werden weil er
eine weil er eine bereitschaft hatte
also auch für den westlichen lebensstil
weil er für deutsche journalisten
gearbeitet hat für amerikanische
journalisten und dass beispielsweise die
frauen die jetzt den duft der freiheit
eingeatmet hat mir den letzten 20 jahren
heute öffentlich geschlagen und
gefeilscht werden umgebracht werden
versteckt werden dass eine burka
auferlegt wird das ist ein
vertrauensbruch nicht nur den frauen
gegenüber sondern auch unserer
wertegemeinschaft und unserer welt
gegenüber und deswegen ist mein appell
dass wir für diese universellen frauen
und menschenrechte einen kurswechsel und
ein paradigmenwechsel brauchen was
europa angeht und was auch einem
menschenrechts geleitete außenpolitik
angeht denn afghanistan ist nicht das
erste und nicht das letzte das wird uns
in der globalisierten welt in zukunft
begleiten und wir brauchen ein
leadership und eine außenpolitik
die beispielsweise pakistan dafür
sanktioniert dass sie gerade den letzten
fleck afghanistans wo es noch widerstand
gegen die taliban grad mit sag ich mal
mit bombardiert und wir wir verhalten
uns dazu nicht sondern ich höre die
ganze zeit nur dass wir mit der taliban
verhandeln müssen während die frauen da
im schmerz sitzen für unsere werte für
freiheit für liberalität und auf der
anderen seite gehen wir denn her und
haben angst freude unterwanderung des
abendlandes und dem ganzen populismus
der dazugehört und da frage ich mich wo
bleibt unsere authentizität wo bleibt
unsere menschlichkeit und ich wünsche
mir und das ist der hauptgrund warum ich
heute hier bin dass wir humanitäres
aufenthaltsrecht und sonderkontingent
geschaffen für diese frauen ich weiß
dass wir nicht alle rausholen können und
darum geht es auch nicht aber wir müssen
die oppositionskräfte stärken wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass kinder mädchen jung
zur schule gehen können und dass wir
lebens würdige menschenwürdige
verhältnisse schaffen und das schaffen
wir mit der politik die wir gegenwärtig
machen überhaupt nicht eine wende in
afghanistan halte ich auch für notwendig
aber nicht so wie sie das hier fordern
denn das halte ich für ganz blind
entschuldigung dass ich das so direkt
sagen
ich bin am wochenende in der meinung die
sich in mir so ausgebildet hat bestätigt
worden fühlte mich bestätigt durch die
frauen demonstrationen an zwei tagen in
kabul frauen gehen auf die straße
fordern ihre rechte
demonstrieren inmitten der taliban und
sagen dann den taliban die ihnen
gegenüber treten wir sind nicht mehr so
wie vor 20 jahren das sind sehr
selbstbewusste starke frauen und ich
glaube wir machen ein riesenfehler wenn
wir die intelligenz afghanistans die
gebildeten die mutigen die freiheits
orientierten zu uns holen und aus dem
land nie behauptet dass wir alle wohl
ich sage das ist auch nicht planen aber
sind sie wollen wesentliche leute holen
die sollen dort bleiben ich will die
leute
lassen lebenswerte fahrerinnen sind mit
lebensgefahr sie reden von denen die der
taliban widersprechen aber reden sie
auch von denen die geschlagen werden die
verprügelt werden die sich bei uns
melden was antwort stehen dass herr
jörges gesagt hat ihr seid wichtig für
afghanistan deswegen hat sie umgebracht
wie der diskussion nicht unfair da bin
ich nicht genau was wieder ein
widersprechen diese afghanische
gesellschaft muss diskussionsfähig
werden und veränderungsfähigkeit die
menschen die wir rausholen wollen wenn
wir das systematisch tun in großer zahl
sind diejenigen das sind der kern einer
neuen opposition das sind die kern der
kern derjenigen die die gesellschaft
wieder in bewegung setzen das ist die
hefe die die gesellschaft in bewegung
der wember die wegholen sind die taliban
mit den ungebildeten allein das licht
bei den reisen des gastes rahmen
schlechten richtig wie das mussten wir
müssen ganz kurz auch der schule anlass
müssen wir die beiden auseinander setzen
wir können doch diskutieren
die schuld wie wir auf uns geladen haben
war dass wir nicht den mut hatten in
deutschland die ganz nüchtern der
wahrheit zu sagen beim beginn des
afghanistan- feldzuges wir wollen die
taliban dort ausräuchern mehr wollten
wir nicht diese seltsame erzählung hat
nur in deutschland stattgefunden dass
wir wegen der mädchenschulen da
reingehen und weil wir einfach nicht
ertragen in unserer gesellschaft dass
wir mit waffengewalt irgendwo unterwegs
sind sondern wir geben dem immer eine
moralisch höheren auftrag und dieser
auftrag hat nie existiert und er hat
auch nicht funktioniert man muss sich
einfach klarmachen dass die afghanische
gesellschaft aus vier großen gruppen
besteht und diese zivilgesellschaft die
wir als nation building voraussetzen
würden die dann einen kern bildet der
stärker wird und sich selbst dann gegen
die taliban nun macht diese existiert
eben nicht un-bericht alles jetzt
zusammen wo ihr wieder rausgehen diese
schuld haben wir auf uns geladen das
muss man einfach ganz klar sagen aber
aus meiner sicht kann die
schlussfolgerung darin nur bestehen
künftig sich rauszuhalten aus solchen
geschichten wir erleben in mali dass wir
nichts segensreiches dort bewirken wir
sind im kosovo vor unserer eigenen
haustür seit über 20 jahren und schaffen
es nicht kosovaren und serben
einigermaßen friedlich auseinander zu
halten man muss sich von der idee
trennen dass man mit waffengewalt
irgendwo auf der welt ruhe schafft und
dann dort etwas blühendes gedeiht das
ist in deutschland gelungen aber das ist
ein ziemlich singulärer fall und man
muss sich das sehr gut angucken wo man
da rein geht man muss alle zivilen
kräfte stärken aber man darf sich keine
illusionen machen dass man auf diese art
und weise wie wir in afghanistan jetzt
gerade gescheitert sind irgendwo anders
am ende müssen wir nach den einnahmen
sein wir müssen uns selbst gehören die
letzte meinung sein er wolle ja ich
teile ihre empörung ich hab sie in
dieser sendung auch gemacht bezogen aber
auch den amerikanischen präsidenten der
unglaublichsten jetzt geht er ihnen die
amerikaner davon also wirklich wie ein
hühnerhaufen
das sind 19 18 jährige mädchen die noch
nie unter der scharia in diese
veränderung gibt da heißt nämlich jetzt
formiert die haben ihren schutzschirm
darüber gelegt und dann sagt er unser
freund mit der pilotenbrille ray-ban im
weißen haus sagt ok sorry das war aus
wir sind draußen wir lassen die
afghanische armee im regen stehen ich
kann ihre empörung nachvollziehen und
jetzt kommt für mich das große ab was
war das große problem 2015 dort hat man
angefangen aus dieser sehr
gerechtfertigten empörung heraus den
rechtsstaat aus den angeln zu helfen
habe gesagt mein gott dieses unheil auf
der ganzen welt jetzt sind wir gefordert
sage hier ich lenke ihre empörung auf
das gerechte ziel und sage okay jetzt
müssen wir die amerikaner zeigen dass
sie nicht nur irgendwo einen krieg
anfangen können sondern dass sie die
leute auch gegen köln nicht dass sie
einfach den europäern permanent
sozusagen den die die nebenwirkungen die
kollateralschäden ihrer völlig kopflose
politik überlassen die amerikaner sind
gefordert zweitens sind natürlich auch
diese gigantischen größe staaten da
diese emirate und wie sie alle heißen
die da in gold und ein ferrari sehr
schwierig machen eigentlich muss ich
unser breites
ja auch
nicht deswegen bis
sie merken man braucht mehr produktiven
streiten
[Musik]